the 1 plus 7 Pro is a really nice device
and at a starting price that sounded
surprisingly low after all of its
features and specs were revealed it's
got a beautiful super smooth display
dual stereo speakers and top-of-the-line
performance specs but after spending a
week with it I have to say I wouldn't
buy it now don't get me wrong it's not a
bad phone by any means in fact its
industry-leading in multiple areas but
it's not without its flaws and in many
areas it's just good not great I'll let
you know exactly what those are
including which phone I'd buy instead
but first let's talk about what they got
right the exterior not only looks nice
but feels very premium aluminum
sandwiched by curved Gorilla Glass
subtle logo and text on the back
perfectly located buttons in the same
triple mute switch that I loved and
hefty weight that adds to the premium
feel we don't have a waterproofing
rating but various videos and breakdown
stuff shown it's up to the task so I
wouldn't worry about it the center of
attention is this massive curved OLED
display coming in at 6 point 7 inches
it's fairly bright has great color
accuracy and is super sharp as you can
see there isn't any kind of notch or
cutout and at the same time we have very
slim bezels not only that but the 90
Hertz refresh rate paired with great
soccer it makes using it the most smooth
experience I've ever had in any
smartphone to make this full screen
experience possible oneplus designed a
motorized front-facing camera and I
think this is probably the best solution
for the notch issue they showed it
holding around 50 pounds of weight which
is crazy and say it's rated for over
300,000 actuations so I don't think
durability will be an issue but only
time will tell
inside of that pop-up camera is a really
good 16 megapixel f/2 selfie camera and
on the back we have three more in a
layout that's been very popular recently
a standard a telephoto and an ultra
light one Plus chose to go with a 48
megapixel main camera instead of apples
and Samsung's 12 megapixel and on the
telephoto we have an 8 megapixel three
times zoom which was actually found out
to be a 13 megapixel 2.2 times that they
crop into which does make sense since
the zoom and images don't look much
better than the two time systems cropped
in digitally the photo and video
capabilities are much better than any
previous one Plus device and are very
good overall but is it enough to take on
the flagships no not really many images
look fantastic but it's in consider
some shots turn out perfect while many
others have highlights pulled down too
much and others have too much contrast
or denoising the same inconsistencies
show up in video as well and some things
are just plain missing like video
recording with the wide-angle lens the
actual sensors are great but the
software still needs tweaking which does
mean oneplus can improve it but at this
time the 7 Pro can't compare with the
tennis max or sn+ if you want to see our
detailed camera comparison I'll link it
at the end of this video although the
camera software needs work I have to say
it again oneplus has the best Android
software the icons shortcuts keyboards
and quick animations are better than
even stock Android and we finally have
an out-of-the-box screen recorder this
wouldn't be possible without great
hardware in a typical oneplus fashion we
have a flagship snapdragon 855 processor
with a ton of RAM up to 12 gigabytes in
fact and oneplus can actually make use
of that Ram with their Ram booster that
preload software add in brand-new UF s3
storage which in the real world doubles
read and write speeds and you have a
crazy fast phone that loads apps
noticeably faster than a competition the
under display optical fingerprint
scanner in my opinion is now just as
good as a physical one and is definitely
ahead of Samsung's ultrasonic scanner
Elise and speed so that's a bunch of
great features of the oneplus 7 pro and
when you pair that with the $700 price
tag for the model that most will likely
choose the 8 gigabyte of ram 256
gigabyte storage i'm using the value
proposition is incredible so why
wouldn't I buy one the biggest culprit
is this the galaxy s 10 plus and also
the fact that just two months later it's
been deeply discounted on multiple
websites bringing it down from the
thousand dollars I paid to as low as
$700 for an international model or just
a bit more for a snapdragon version that
is crazy i will leave some links in the
video description for some of the deals
I've found if the oneplus 7 pro was
released half a year ago it would have
destroyed the market war FS + + theta
300 dollars more than the 7 pro it would
be a no-brainer but with the Samsung
flagship being available so close in
price the oneplus is hard to recommend
for most when we compare them
side-by-side the oneplus falls behind in
too many areas the battery charger is
super fast but you have to use both
their proprietary charger and
able in the four thousand milliamp
battery is large but the 90 Hertz
display drains the battery so much that
I couldn't ever get a full day of use
like a can with as ten which still has
10 to 15 percent battery lights
remaining to make matters worse we still
don't have wireless charging so you
can't leave it on the stand to top off
throughout the day I understood it at
$530 but I think at this price point
paired with the pro name and high
battery drain oneplus definitely needed
to include it the display is nice but
also can't compete Samsung's is quite a
bit brighter and the HDR videos look
much better on that is 10 and the same
thing goes for the speakers that's 10
pluses blow the oneplus 7 pro savage
seer speakers away in both sound quality
and volume
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's nice not having a cut out but the
curved portion of the screen start
spending much earlier so reflections are
a bigger issue if you like listening to
music and watching videos on your phone
the s10 is definitely a ways ahead the
stems camera quality is much more
consistent and overall better in both
photos and video especially for the
ultra wide lens where the photos are far
ahead because of processing and they're
wider and on top of that you can
actually use video recording including
that super cool super steady feature you
do get 128 gigabytes of slower but still
fast storage as the base but the SD card
slot will accept up to another 512
gigabytes and for those that use wired
headphones we still have a headphone
jack and I'm leaving my biggest
complaint for laughs and that's the size
and the weight I never thought I'd say
but this smartphone screen is just too
big and I love large screens but six
point seven inches paired with 206 grams
means that in some of my pockets it
actually sticks out my hands were
noticeably more tired when watching
YouTube for a while and playing games
compared to the s10 Plus which is
smaller thinner and almost 20% lighter
while still having a large six point
four inch display in the real world this
phone will be too large for most people
and that's before adding a case the one
plus seven pro is a really nice phone
that leads in multiple areas but to
achieve that they had to raise the cost
at the same time the competition has
really upped its game and is still ahead
like they were in previous years if your
number one priority is a super smooth
experience both including the specs the
software and the displays 90 Hertz then
it could still make sense but for most
people if you could spend just a little
bit more money I think the s10 is a much
better choice thank you guys for
watching if you want to see more videos
on the oneplus 7 pro you guys can click
on right over there and if you guys want
to subscribe click that little circle
above and go ahead and enable
notifications if you don't want to miss
out on future videos this has been max
with max tech and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]